la naissance d'un véritable marché de la
croissance de multiples méthodes
existent aujourd'hui pour faire grandir
des enfants trop petits les
scientifiques ont réussi à mettre au
point depuis plusieurs années des
hormones de synthèse qui ont donc
totalement bouleversé la proche de ce
problème un programme un progrès qui
pose aussi des questions scientifiques
et éthiques à un colloque international
se tient actuellement à paris
jean pierre casaux six jours sur sept
depuis plusieurs mois juliette prépare
sa piqûre son traitement l'hormone de
croissance
et c'est en pensant à 14 ans juliette
mesure 1 m 35
elle a toujours été plus petit que ses
camarades mais surtout il y a un an
les médecins pour ça fait une anomalie
de cette courbe de croissance et un
déficit parcelles en hormones pronostics
à l'époque une taille adulte avec les
traitements la courbe de croissance
c'est déjà normalisée maintenant elle
peut espérer avoir une pâte presque
normale
pourtant il y a quelques années juliette
n'auraient pas d'effets traité on va
certainement vers un assouplissement et
une évolution des indications
particulier faire les cas limiter les
déficits partiel le deuxième congrès sur
la croissance qui a débuté aujourd'hui à
paris a constaté cette évolution dans
les indications
un chiffre en témoignent quelques
centaines d'enfants étaient traités en
france il ya cinq ans près de 4000 le
sont aujourd'hui
mais s'il existe des équipes
spécialisées dans toutes les régions de
france
on constate encore des retards dans le
diagnostic initial ce qui font se
détecter un retard de croissance le plus
rapidement possible
pour abaisser l'âge de traitement actuel
qui est en moyenne de 10 ans pour les
enfants en france alors que les dans les
pays européens
la moyenne d'âge pour un traitement par
hormone de croissance est de 5 ans la
bonne de croissance est actuellement
commercialisé en france par cinq
laboratoires différents
c'est sans doute le meilleur signe d'un
marché en plein développement